and we're joined in the studio by Brian
Woods who is the music director creative
in Residence of the World Chess Hall of
a Fame and you're here to tell us all
about the World Chess Hall of Fame music
series tell us about the the World Chess
Hall of Fame music series of course well
I run all the classical programming at
the World Chess Hall of Fame so what I
do is I partner with people from the St
Louis Symphony from Opera Theater St
Louis internationally renowned soloists
who come in and perform on our monthly
series I partner with Brian Owens who
you had earlier in the tournament to put
on this incredible music series that we
have I could not be prouder of the work
that we're doing the level of
musicianship and the collaborations that
we're doing I mean yaser I have to brag
on you a little bit because this this
month I mean we put on a show all about
um Serge bofia David Oyo their famous
chess match that took place and the
music that was inspired by the chess and
I mean the the chat that you gave us the
pre-concert talk all about how pv's
chess game had a bearing on his artistic
output was just such an incredible thing
to hear and see and and you know I was
privileged to play with the assistant
concert Master of the St Louis Symphony
and give a fantastic show I mean those
kinds of collaborations you're not going
to find anywhere else I'm very I'm very
proud of that that was fun at the world
CH Hall of Fame that was a very special
evening and the lady that performed with
you that night yes Hannah G was her name
wow she was terrific wow you're going to
be hosting the Gaya along with your
cohort and cry Bri yes I know my partner
in cryan the other Brian I always say
you can just shout the name Brian
somewhere on the chess campus and
someone will turn their head you know
there's plenty of us but U we're so
looking forward to this on December 2nd
um not only are we the MC's for the
evening but we're going to be performing
um celebrating just all the cultural
impact that chess has not just in St
Louis but but everywhere I mean between
musical theater and pop music I'll be
playing a set of classical music just a
an incredible evening in support of of
the uh the public programming that we do
as well as the educational programming
but like I said just a celebration of
Chess and everything that it relates to
in culture and of course it's our Gaya
where we have the silent auction which
is actually open open you get out the I
know get the bids going everyone it's
not going to be open forever there you
go and I always encourage folks just to
check out the incredible offerings we
have on that silent auction um I was
very privileged to donate u a private
concert to the um silent auction as I
think Brian Owens also donated private
concert along with season tickets which
we're very excited about for our 2024
season which has been announced let me
brag on you for just a moment I don't
mind cuz we've got some uh performance
of you we uh yeah we're going to show
that yeah we're we were very very
pleased to here we
[Music]
go
were you really into the music what's
going on right there what is going on
right there I I I think there's a
combination of you know I'm up there to
to do a job technically and so there's a
considerations of of what's happening at
the instrument a justing to maybe things
that don't always go the same way every
single time but there's also a message
to communicate and music is all about
connecting with other people and tell
them a story and so I think in that
sense you also have that responsibility
to project a story um towards folks and
you know I always say maybe people think
I'm wrong here but I I think there's so
many overlaps between chess and music
just because there's um it's this idea
of just creativity in a structure you
know there's only there's limitations to
you know the boundaries of what are a
available for us to do but there's
infinite possibilities and so between
you know I always feel such a
partnership between chess and live music
in that sense I see that and I see such
emotion me too and I was going to ask
you um do you have to strive for
Perfection when you're playing these
yes with a lot of work we strive for
goodness Perfection is a little I mean
do you have to be no perfect because
obviously a con you would love to be you
know things happen every time you
perform that you know it's never perfect
but it's a it's a lifelong pursuit of of
that uh I call it I I would say
Excellence perhaps as the the pursuit of
um and it's not just like I said it's
not just the technical it's also the
more you can achieve technically and the
more you have a Mastery over the
instrument the better you're able to
tell that story and connect with folks
in the music so it's a it's a both and
in that situation I would say I I love
that answer and uh well speaking about
the future what is in store for the 2024
World Chess Hall of Fame music series
I'm so excited for this we have so many
collaborations like I said with the St
Louis Symphony with Opera Theater St
Louis with winter Opera we have artists
coming from out of town we have some of
the best artists in St Louis um I myself
been performing a couple
times which I'm happy to do and U but
again it's it's the it's the idea of
collaboration that I'm always so excited
about it's this sense of we don't exist
on our own you know there's so much
music around us that we can feel feat
and and promote and enjoy together and I
just love having that platform um at the
witch off music series and um our season
tickets are available now you can check
that out on worldest h.org oh thank you
so much Brian joining us thank you for
having me and we're looking forward to
seeing you mcing at the oh yes ATA we're
we're going to Regala you with all kinds
of things promise holding a YouTube all
right I'll see you there yeah Ryan keep
up the search for excellence thank you
very much thanks for having me great to
have show let's take a look at our
results so far